today we held an interesting orientation
debate on an amended regulation on the
coordination of social security systems
on the basis of a presidential note
thanks to the cross-border coordination
European citizens can safeguard their
social security entitlement that is
without any doubt an urgent need to
adapt the EU legislation to the user
conferences and to codify the recent
case laws employment opportunities for
instance we see that they are not
distributed evenly across european union
and therefore job seekers needs to be
mobile secondly we want to clarify the
rules on the long-term care benefits how
they are treated in cross-border
situations and which long-term kan care
benefit services may be entitled when
they are moving abroad and thirdly we
address the question of which social
benefits economically inactive citizens
can claim outside their home country let
me be clear free movement does not mean
unconditional free access to social
benefits in other countries inequality
at the labour market does not only have
long lasting social consequences but it
also impacts as I already said on
economic growth with this in mind we
tabled the council conclusions on
enhancing the skills on women and men in
the EU labour market I am glad to recall
that consensus was reached on this text
today the council has the policy debate
on the European semester of the current
here we discussed how to enhance labour
market access and reduce divergences
across the EU there was general
agreement that the situation is
improving in terms of economic growth
and job creation but that there is no
room for complacency we've covered lots
of ground but still a long way to go
this year I'm happy to say that the
implementation of policy reforms through
the European semester is clearly bearing
fruits we see that the employment has
never been so high in Europe
also youth employment and long-term
unemployment are dropping and the number
of people at risk of poverty or social
exclusion has decreased in Europe even
if the level remains high another area
where the European Union is fortunately
making good progress is health and
safety at the workplace we also realize
that small and medium sized enterprises
have sometimes difficulties implementing
these standards by addressing
occupational safety and health in SMS we
have an opportunity to make a real
difference for millions of workers
because we all know SMEs are the biggest
employees in Europe